let's talk about bitcoin bitcoin's a
very interesting asset i think in that
there's people who make the argument
it's the most macro asset out there it's
kind of the free market um there's
people who would argue that it's an
inflation hedge and it served as a great
inflation it's up hundreds of percent
since the start of the pandemic but is
down you know 50 plus percent over the
last couple of months like
what are your views on bitcoin and how
do you think of that asset given kind of
the macro backdrop
well the thing that's interesting about
bitcoin i've been interested in bitcoin
since i think i first bought it in um
2012 maybe okay and uh we we invested in
a number of we're not a crypto investor
but we did um express
uh a thesis back in 2017 2018 that we
thought that crypto would graduate from
being into being a institutional asset
classroom being really more of a
consumer retail phenomenon and so we
ended up investing
in institutional custody through a
company called bitco and we also
invested in multi we're the seed
investor multi-coin capital which was a
crypto focused hedge fund we basically
believe that you know that as crypto
matured into an asset class you would
need specialized fund managers of which
we were not really i'm a sas investor so
but i'm like but let's invest in these
guys because they're focused on the
problem
so we expressed the number of these
views and it generally has worked out
very well for us um
but anyway so i've been interested in
bitcoin for a while and i think the
transformational part of bitcoin is this
idea that we could have non-fiat money
right we just as we're talking about
with the fed um there is a huge risk of
currency debasement when the government
is in control and particularly when you
have the world's reserve currency
there's just such an enormous temptation
to print money to finance your budget
and to rack up loans that become
unpayable we're at what like 130
of gdp now we own we owe
so we owe an amount of money greater
than the size of our entire economy or
our economic output that sounds very
hard to repay to me
so the temptation will eventually be to
monetize the debt away basically to
debase the currency to pay for this debt
that's always been a risk throughout
history and
now what bitcoin offers is
a different
kind of currency where it's not backed
by a government it's backed by math it's
backed by encryption and so you don't
have to trust the government
uh that there will only be 21 million
bitcoin it's in the it's in the code
and so you just have to trust that
that the um that bitcoin effectively
won't be cracked you know you just have
to believe
that the system is secure
and i think a lot of people might over
time
gradually think that's a better form of
money